gay à 28 ans il habite toujours chez ses
parents
tanguy aux états unis ça se termine
devant la justice je t'aime maman
un juge de syracuse vient de trancher
michael rotonde au 30 ans va devoir
quitter la maison de ses parents
ça a commencé en octobre ils m'ont dit
il te faut un travail une assurance et
puis ils lui ont envoyé des avis 5 dont
un daté de l'année 2000 108 où il lui
offre 1100 $ pour se trouver un autre
toit mais rien à faire
ils exigent six mois pour tenter de
s'organiser
c'est scandaleux qu'il juge qui n'attend
plus que l'ordre d'expulsion pour le
signer l'avion a l'air bien qu'on est
chez nous l'issue ne serait pas
différente
c'est leur droit à leur propriété le
droit d'être chez soi
l'enfant n'a pas un droit d'habitation à
usage indéfini jusqu'à l'âge de 100 ans
chez ces parents là haut dit que les
enfants sont comme des boomerangs mais
sa part ça revient sa part sarah qui
vont être à ces gars là est un homme que
j'aurai fait mon travail pour pour les
amener à l'autonomie c'est ma job de
parents un couple de matane a dû aller
jusqu'en justice l'automne dernier pour
que leur fils quittent leur chalet et
qu'il puisse le vendre
il a eu dix jours et il est parti mais
le soutien des parents il peut être
nécessaire
c'est un enfant un projet de vie par
exemple veut faire un doctorat qui
veulent amener à avoir un travail donc
les parents devront continuer à l'aider
il habite toujours chez ses parents
aucun doute le syndrome tanguy ça reste
une gentille je pense que je me rendrai
jusqu'aux tribunaux mais quoi
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal